bonjour jacques benillouche merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
quelles sont les raisons qui ont conduit
le hamas à signer cet accord de
cessez-le-feu avec israël alors ce que
je peux dire c'est que c'est un accord à
minima parce que les revendications de
part et d'autre et est complètement
différente
seulement depuis le 6 août il y a un
cycle qui s'étend en engranger et qui
consistait à des ballots incendiaires
donc des incendies a eu quatre sortes et
de l'autre côté des frappes israéliennes
mais on peut dire lui dans ce cadre là
il y avait une certaine modération des
deux côtés parce qu'il n'ya pas eu deux
demi s'il n'y a pas eu de requête
envoyée depuis le parlera masse sur les
zones isralienne dessus et il n'y a pas
eu non plus de bord qu'on se fait par
l'aviation israélienne qui a tiré on le
dit sur des vieilles pierres sur des
bâtiments vides sur des des maisons déjà
détruites et donc cette de cette
modération relative a été nécessaire
parce qu'il y avait depuis un moment des
négociations qui avaient lieu
ces négociations avaient lieu sous
l'égide de l'egypte qui faisait touré
qui a tout fait pour essayer d'arranger
les choses entre le frat-mat leur hamas
israël
alors pourquoi 7,1 c'est un jeudi reste
un accord à minima parce que les deux
parties avaient des avait des objectifs
tout à fait différente le pour israël il
s'agit c'est avant tout d'obtenir la
libération de deux prisonniers civils
qui sont en israël à gaza depuis un
certain temps et la restitution de deux
des deux corps de militaires tués durant
la guerre 2002 de 2014
et ça c'était le ccc permanent chaque
fois les deux morceaux paix or le gaz
allait gaza ne peut pas se défaire de
cet accord parce que c'est un moyen pour
lui de faire chanter entre les
guillemets israël et de l'autre côté
israël est bien de la côte et le rat
masqué vous pouvez avoir beaucoup de
chose et que de lui donne pas extrêmes
temps justement tant que les causes ne
sont pas restitués
alors ils voudraient je me permets de
vous vous coupez jacques beynet où je
vous le disais tout à l'heure la
situation est tendue 1 depuis le 6 août
dernier avec des violences pratiquement
quotidiennes dans une part et d'autre
aujourd'hui vraiment quelle est la
situation à gaza de ses traits la
situation est calme à la frontière
il n'y a plus rien il ya plus de chin il
n'y a plus de temps il ya encore de
temps en temps quelques réacteurs
du côté du jihad islamique mais sont mis
au pas ils sont mis au pas l'ours qui
est certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y à
un intermédiaire qatari qui est venu qui
se trouve à l'heure actuelle en erreur à
gaza qui est venu avec les valises
pleines d'argent comme il le fait de
manière régulière et je vous disais qui
a minima parce que les des gens de l'est
alsace où est passé à 30 millions de
dollars
tous les mois or que le qatar a dit
qu'il en donnerait que seulement feu que
10 millions d'autre part les lignes à un
chômage de 50% à gaza et donc le ramasse
voudrait qu'on en voit un peu plus
d'ouvriers palestiniens en israël en
jusqu'à présent il n'y avait
officiellement entre guillemets pas
d'ouvriers qui venaient en israël
c'étaient des hommes d'affaires dans sa
maintenant officiellement on annonce que
ce sont des ouvriers qui sont
d'excellents ouvriers pour la
construction israël a beaucoup besoin de
main d'oeuvre pour la construction qui
sont d'excellents ouvriers pour
l'agriculture vous avez des zones et les
implantations et qui laisse leur ca à
leur arbre lors lors leurs arbres
pourrir sur place parce qu'ils n'ont
personne pour enlever les free est donc
eu tout le monde trouve son intérêt
égoïste est certainement faire un effort
pour recevoir ses 10000 avec intérêt
mais on sait que à l'heure actuelle il
ya une certaine effervescence depuis là
depuis la signature de l'accord entre
les émirats et il sera une certaine
concurrence
vous savez que le qatar et médecins et
de l'ana lié à porter d'u
masse parce qu'ils ont la même idéologie
c'est à dire l'idéologie des frères
musulmans mais on voit maintenant et là
on va se voir très vite on sent qu'il ya
une certaine concurrence avec les
émirats pourquoi les émirats parce que
les émirats héberge depuis un certain
temps un concurrent de mahmoud abbas qui
est mohamed dahlan l'ancien homme fort
de gaza et lui voudrait reprend pied à
gaza
en reprenant bien gaza il m'a reprend
effectivement essayé de reprendre la
place de mahmoud abbas
et donc on va se retrouver devant devant
cette concurrence entre les émirats et
le qatar qui risque d'apporter un peu de
dix ans de conflit
alors cette fois-ci interarabes et donc
pour l'instant on peut dire que la
situation va ce style et israël a tout
fait pour obtenir cet accord de cessez
fut là le jour de la rentrée scolaire
on ne pouvait pas se permettre on ne
peut pas se permettre en israël d'avoir
des ballots d'un sander ou des missiles
qui tombent sur les écoles et dont
c'était un accord qui est qu'elle chacun
y trouve son compte
mais pas tout à fait parce que les gars
ça voudrait qu'on étende sa son lieu de
7 son espace de pêche et israël n'a pas
accepté ils ont limité simplement
l'espace de pêche
il voudrait étendre la zone industrielle
de gaza si la freebox
merci beaucoup je suis désolé de vous
couper merci beaucoup
jacques benillouche d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste indépendant
merci beaucoup